foreign
here's what I want to know Heaven is
turning 18. she is man are you prepared
for that I'm excited my little girl is
growing up she's excited excited is the
word we've used too
as Kevin Hart's daughter Heaven tears up
over her graduation present yep a new
car you know she's uh about to embark on
the world of college I mean life after
the heart household is now presenting
itself the Hart family documents the 18
year old's emotional reaction on
Instagram
teeny bit more
Heaven's mom and Kevin's ex-wife Tori
was in the crowd the message for her
parents good job guys
foreign
for a long period of time you look at
your kids kids the kids right and then
as they get older and start to mature
you're like these are young adults of
course Heaven's grad party was a true
Family Affair the comedian and Tori's
son Hendrix was there as was Kevin and
his wife aniko's two kids son Kenzo and
daughter kaori when you got kids uh that
Embrace that Embrace their sibling you
know it's it's the the best feeling in
the world as a parent with that in mind
pick on the gram yeah all four heart
kiddos who Heaven calls my best friends
just to see your kids sit and get along
and play and take on that role of Big
Sister Big Brother Hendrick supported
his sis for another Milestone over the
weekend
that's Heaven posing with her dad ahead
of the prom making her night to remember
that much more special not to mention
this tribute from her dad I have no
words just pure joy my little girl
looked unbelievable yesterday where does
the time go she's excited about the next
steps in her life will you drop her off
at College will you take her she'll move
out of the heart house absolutely
absolutely will you be the dad who cries
ow I'm probably gonna cry the baby you
know
um
I got I got four kids though so it's not
like the households empty right still
yeah
it'll be tough it'll be tough I'm not
even gonna try the front it'll be tough
that's what I was gonna say don't forget
that's mine that's my little girl I'm
probably gonna break down even with
Heaven flying the coop in the fall
something tells us there will be plenty
of Epic father-daughter adventures in
that new ride all summer long
hahaha
congrats on being the first